welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday
[Music]
life I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a
professor of neurobiology and
Opthalmology at Stanford school of
medicine today we are discussing working
memory working memory is a special
category of memory in which we are able
to hold small amounts of information in
our mind for short periods of time
working memory is also very closely
related to attention so for any of you
that are interested in how to develop
better focus and attention understanding
what working memory is and some of the
things that you can do to improve your
working memory can be very beneficial
today I'm going to talk about what
working memory is including some of the
underlying biology although I promise
irrespective of whether or not you know
any biology or you are an expert in
biology I'll make the conversation
accessible to you in addition I will
talk about tools to improve working
memory and I'll also compare working
memory to other forms of memory memory
like long-term memory and short-term
memory and through that understanding
I'm confident that you'll be able to
develop better focus as well as be able
to commit certain forms of information
to your short and long-term memory
stores before we begin I'd like to
emphasize that this podcast is separate
for my teaching and research roles at
Stanford it is however part of my desire
and effort to bring zero cost to
Consumer information about science and
science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is matina
matina makes loose leaf and ready to
drink ybba mate I often discuss ybba
mate's benefits such as regulating blood
sugar it's high antioxidant content the
ways that it can improve digestion and
possible neuroprotective effects I also
drink yamate because I love the taste
while there are a lot of different
choices of yerbamate drinks out there I
love matina because again they have the
no sugar variety as well as the fact
that both their loose leaf and their
canned varieties are of the the absolute
best quality so much so that I decided
to become a partial owner in the company
although I must say even if they hadn't
allowed me to do that I would be
drinking matina is the cleanest tasting
and best yerbamate you can find I love
the taste of brooded loose leaf matina
yerbamate and I particularly love the
taste of maa's new canned cold brew zero
sugar yerbamate which I personally help
them develop if you'd like to try matina
go to drink maa.com Huber
Right Now matina is offering a free one
PB bag of loose leaf yerbamate tea and
free shipping with the purchase of two
cases of their cold brew yamate again
that's drink maa.com huberman to get the
free bag of yamate looseleaf tea and
free shipping today's episode is also
brought To Us by betterhelp betterhelp
offers Professional Therapy with a
licensed therapist carried out online
now I've been going to therapy for well
over 30 years initially I didn't have a
choice it was a condition of being
allowed to stay in school but pretty
soon I realized that therapy is
extremely valuable in fact I consider
doing regular therapy just as important
as getting regular exercise including
cardiovascular exercise and resistance
training which of course I also do every
week the reason I know therapy is so
valuable is that if you can find a
therapist with whom you can develop a
really good rapport you not only get
terrific support for some of the
challenges in your life but you also can
derive tremendous insights from that
therapy insights that can allow you to
better not just your emotional life and
your relationship life but of of course
also the relationship to yourself and to
your professional life to all sorts of
career goals in fact I see therapy is
one of the key components for meshing
together all aspects of one's life and
being able to really direct one's focus
and attention toward what really matters
if you'd like to try betterhelp go to
betterhelp.com huberman to get 10% off
your first month again that's
betterhelp.com
huberman today's episode is also brought
To Us by Helix sleep helix IC sleep
makes mattresses and pillows that are of
the absolute highest quality I've spoken
many times before on this and other
podcast about the fact that sleep is the
foundation of mental health physical
health and performance one of the key
things to getting a great night's sleep
is to make sure that your mattress
matches your sleep requirements the
Helix website has a brief two-minute
quiz that if you go to it will ask you
questions such as do you sleep on your
back your side or your stomach do you
tend to run hot or cold during the
middle of the night as well as some
other questions that allow you to
determine the optimal mattress for you
when I took the quiz I personally
matched to their dusk mattress D which
has allowed me to significantly improve
my sleep so if you're interested in
significantly improving your sleep go to
helixsleep.com
huberman take their brief two-minute
quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress and you'll get up to
$350 off any mattress order and two free
pillows so again if you're interested in
trying Helix go to helixsleep.com
huberman for up to $350 off and two fore
free pillows okay let's talk about
working memory and let's start off this
discussion by comparing working memory
to other forms of memory that most
people are more familiar with or at
least when most people hear the word
memory they typically are thinking about
long-term memory like one's ability to
remember the capitals of states or
countries the different continents
directions from one location to another
even one's name all of those things are
examples of long-term memory now I want
to emphasize that long-term memory
really has two components there are what
we call declarative long-term memories
so these are the things that we can
declare things like facts about
ourselves or the world or others and
then there are procedural long-term
memories procedural long-term memories
as the name suggests are aspects of our
memory that allow us to perform certain
procedures they are literally action
steps that we take to for instance ride
a bicycle or drive a car which by the
way we might not be conscious of
ourselves doing after we learn that is
after we pass information into our
procedural long-term memory but even
once those things become reflexive they
are stored in our long-term memory now a
discussion of long-term memory is not
the focus today but me being a
neuroscientist and I like to think you
all generally being interested in the
underlying biology I'll just mention
that there's a key structure within the
brain that is part of a larger neural
network that is a collection of
structures which is absolutely essential
for the formation and storage of
long-term memories and that's the
hippocampus which in Latin means
seahorse and it does look a little bit
like a seahorse but you actually have
one on each side of your brain so we say
hippocampi plural and so what we know is
that if people have damage to their
hippocampus of any kind that people have
trouble accessing or forming long-term
memory sometimes both and there's a lot
more that we could say about long-term
memory indeed I did an entire episode of
The hubman Lab podcast about the
formation and storage of long-term
memories including some tools to improve
long-term memories we'll touch on a few
of those tools later today but you can
access that episode if you go to hubman
lab.com and just put memory into the
search function and you'll find it there
in the meantime if we want to understand
working memory we not only have to
understand how it's different from
long-term memory but also how it's
different from short-term memories
short-term memory is a capacity that we
all have that as the name suggests
represents a short-term memory bank for
information that may or may not get
passed into long-term memory so for
instance if you've learned anything and
of course you have if you can understand
what I'm saying you've learned English
language if you can write you've learned
how to write Etc well in order to learn
those things and to commit them to
long-term memory the information
required to do those things and to have
that knowledge needed to be held in
short-term memory and short-term
memories are the sorts of memories that
we maintain for somewhere between a few
minutes and potentially a few hours
maybe a little bit longer but only a
certain percentage of that is passed
into our long-term memory so for
instance if you listen to this podcast
or you go to a course lecture uh whether
or not that lecture is about cognitive
material or whether or not it's about
learning a new physical skill regardless
of what you learn you're only going to
learn a certain amount of that
information but were we to examine how
much of the information you just heard
or that you're hearing now you remember
immediately after this podcast episode
as compared to say a week later we know
based on gosh millions of scientific
papers and studies that you are going to
have more information in your short-term
memory stores shortly after being
exposed to new information then you will
later in other words only a small
percentage of what we perceive what we
see what we hear Etc gets passed into
short-term memory and then only a
fraction of that gets passed into
long-term memory now the neural circuits
for short-term memory and the passage of
short-term memories into long-term
memory involve a lot of different brain
structures but here again we can
implicate the hip hi campus Because the
actual passage of short-term memories
into long-term memories occurs in part
within the hippocampus and then a lot of
people don't know this some of the
memories that we think of as long-term
memories are actually distributed into
the neocortex which is the outer portion
of the brain now the point here is less
to fill your mind with different names
of things and nomenclature but rather to
get you thinking about what's involved
in creating short and long-term memories
and equally important that even though
the hippocampus is critically involved
in the formation of short and long-term
memories that the formation of short and
long-term memories is really a network
phenomenon in fact among the more
important themes that comes up again and
again on this podcast anytime that we're
talking about Neuroscience or actually
biology in any case is that rarely if
ever is there one location in the brain
where something happens typically it's a
network phenomenon meaning it's the
collaboration of a bunch of different
brain areas passing information from one
location to the next and storing it in a
kind of distributed way way now another
key thing to understand about working
memory and how it is different from
short and long-term memory is that the
formation of short and long-term
memories almost always involves
neuroplasticity neuroplasticity is the
nervous system's ability to change in
response to experience now there are
different types of neuroplasticity so
often when we hear about neuroplasticity
in the popular sphere people don't
emphasize that there are different types
of neuroplasticity and it's worth paying
a little bit of attention to what those
different typ are there is for instance
what we call long-term potentiation
long-term potentiation or ltp as the
acronym goes is the strengthening of
connections between neurons as a
consequence of their repeated firing
very closely together in time okay
there's a lot more to it but if you've
ever heard the phrase fire together wire
together sometimes that is misattributed
to Donald Hebb who did talk about
neuroplasticity by the way Donald Hebb
was a psychologist up in Canada who
talked about neuroplasticity in the
context of lots of different forms of
learning but that fire together wire
together phrase was not actually stated
by Donald Hebb it was stated by Carla
shatz my colleague at Stanford and she
was referring to ltp but other forms of
neuroplasticity that occur mainly in
development when neurons fire very
closely in time and thereby strengthen
those connections which can include ltp
okay so for now think of ltp as anytime
that some small group of neurons could
be two neurons
could be 2,000 neurons are very active
closely together in time and they have
access to one another physically and the
consequence is often not always but it's
often ltp that is the strengthening of
those connections such that after that
barrage of activity subsides those
neurons can speak to each other they can
communicate through electrical activity
and chemical activity much more easily
their communication is more robust it's
like removing a wall between a a
conversation such that the conversation
can take place more fluidly now there
are other forms of neuroplasticity
including LTD longterm depression which
unfortunately the name often calls to
mind ideas about depression as a
psychiatric or a psychological symptom
but has nothing to do with that
long-term depression is simply the
inverse of ltp it's actually the
weakening or the removal of connections
that we call synapses between neurons I
want to emphasize that both ltp and LTD
are both critically involved in lots of
different kinds of learning and both of
them tend to be involved in the
formation of both short-term memories
and long-term memories and this is very
important in the removal of short-term
memories and long-term memories
literally forgetting of certain things
because as we all know there are many
things that we will never forget and
there are also things that we almost
always forget now there's a third form
of neuroplasticity that's involved in
the formation of short and long-term
memories that's important for us to
discuss just briefly but I do want to
emphasize that there are not just three
forms of neuroplasticity there are many
other forms dozens if not more things
like Spike timing dependent plasticy
paired pulse facilitation and on and on
but the third type of neuroplasticity
that I'd like to mention now is
neurogenesis neurogenesis is the
formation of new neurons now
neurogenesis is robust in the developing
nervous system we know this it's robust
in the developing nervous system of
animals and humans however neurogenesis
the literal formation of new neurons in
the brain is a very exciting idea and it
does occur and it's very exciting in a
way that has motivated lots of popular
press Outlets to talk about or to
discuss papers that have discovered
neurogenesis in the adult brain because
let's be honest what's more exciting
than the idea that your brain can add
new brain cells later in life and indeed
that has been shown even in people well
into their 80s and 90s however it's very
important to know that the total amount
of neurogenesis that occurs in the adult
human brain is infantes small as a
mechanism for neuroplasticity and
learning as compared to the other forms
of neuroplasticity that we discussed
such as long-term potentiation and
long-term depression so I don't want to
you know throw cold water on the topic
of neurogenesis it's an incredibly
interesting and important topic but all
too often they tend to eclipse the much
more common mechanism for the formation
of short and long-term memories which
are those other forms we just talked
about ltp LTD Etc so the point here is
that yes indeed there are new neurons
that can be added in the adult brain
maybe even in the adult human brain and
there is some evidence that some of
those new neurons are added to the
hippocampus in fact a particular region
of the hippocampus called the dentate
gyrus of the hippocampus and there's
been a lot of controversy about how much
neurogenesis occurs or doesn't occur and
whether or not it occurs after puberty
or not there's a whole field of people
battling over this now for several
decades ades but one thing is very clear
neurogenesis while it's very exciting
and intriguing is not the main mechanism
by which the formation of short and
long-term memories occurs when you learn
new information as you are right now the
storage of that information in your
short-term memory networks which is then
passed on to your long-term memory
networks and that can be recalled that
allows you to State certain facts about
for instance the existence of this thing
called a hippocampus hopefully you will
remember that going forward or your
ability to perform any kind of motor
movement that you learned now or way
back in
childhood most of that is the
consequence of the strengthening of
particular connections and the weakening
of other types of connections those are
the two major forms of neuroplasticity
okay so I don't want you to get the
impression that there's something wrong
with my memory and that I forgot that
this episode is not about short or
long-term memory but it's about working
memory and indeed I have not forgotten
so now is where I tell you why I've been
talking about short and long-term memory
and the mechanisms of those because I
want them to provide a stark contrast
for what we call working memory working
memory as far as we know does not
involve neuroplasticity or at least if
it does it's not a particularly robust
aspect of working memory rather working
memory is the reflection of a particular
neural circuit running an algorithm over
and over and over for different types of
information but the information isn't
stored it is actually intentionally
discarded now what sorts of daily
activities and life activities would
require working memory the answer to
that is basically everything that you
need to do but that you don't want to
remember now what types of things would
those be well let's think about it most
all of us learned at some point in our
life to tie our own shoes presumably you
know how to tie your own shoes if you
don't perhaps you should learn or wear
velcro or slippers I don't know but
assuming you can tie your own shoes
that's something that you know how to do
and you can do it as a procedural
long-term memory you can do that action
you don't have to think about it too
much working memory would come into play
when say you wake up in the morning and
you know that you need to head out for a
jog but you also need to make a cup of
coffee first and you need to remember
where the coffee is where your shoes are
and perhaps you're making a phone call
or you're having a conversation while
you need to tie your shoes and so on and
so forth working memory is basically the
taking in of information that's critical
for you to sequence your actions over a
short period of time and then forget
that sequence for instance I'm willing
to bet that you put your shoes on to go
running before you go running that's
sort of a duh and if you're like me you
drink your water your coffee your yante
before you go running the point here is
that if you wake up in the morning and
you like caffeine before you go for a
run there are certain series of action
steps that you need to carry out to
hydrate make that cup of coffee or tea
drink it put on your shoes head out the
door you need to sequence things
properly but you don't want to to commit
your long-term or even your short-term
memory stores to carrying out that
sequence you simply want to be able to
carry out that sequence and then discard
that information about the sequence and
focus your attention on for instance
what trajectory you're going to run
through the park or around your
neighborhood then you want to discard
that information and you want to lean
into the next portion of your day and so
on and so on in fact working memory is
involved in essentially every activity
both cognitive and motor from the point
wake up in the morning until the time
you go to sleep at night for every
single day of your life and we know this
because there are indeed people who have
diminished working memory or even lack
working memory entirely although the
latter is somewhat rare it has happened
and as you can imagine they have a
complete failure of ability to sequence
activities and their lives are extremely
difficult they need a ton of assistance
from other people even more assistants
than do people who have minimal or no
long-term memory okay so this is really
highlighting just how important working
memory is working memory is basically
the way that you navigate any immediate
environment and as I mentioned earlier
it's very closely tied to attention
because in order to know what to do now
and then what to do subsequently and
then subsequent to that you need to be
able to hold your attention to the
things you need to do so working memory
and attention collaborate literally at a
neural circuit level and at a
neurochemical level in order to allow
you to move through your day in an
Adaptive functional way and people who
have challenges with attention or Focus
or working memory and sometimes it can
be hard to dissociate which one they're
having challenges with really have a
hard time moving through life as
compared to people whose attention and
working memory is more robust now the
good news is today we're going to talk
about working memory some of the neural
circuits involved and some of the
neurochemicals involved that can augment
or improve working memory and we're also
going to talk about what one can do to
directly increase the amount of
neurotransmission of those particular
chemicals within the circuits that
control working memory in other words to
improve your working memory now I can
talk about working memory and the
mechanisms Etc all day long but as is
often the case sometimes it's better to
not just learn about Concepts but
actually to experience them in real time
so what we're going to do now is I'm
actually going to give you a working
memory test this is the sort of working
memory test that you would take if you
were to go into a psychology laboratory
or a neuroscience Laboratory and they
were studying working memory in humans
now there's another advantage to us
doing this in real time right here as
you're listening or as you're listening
and watching and that's because you're
going to get data you're going to get
information about what your Baseline
working memory capacity is and you're
going to want to keep those data in your
short-term memory stores maybe even your
long-term memory stores but certainly
your short-term memory stores because
shortly later in this episode I'm going
to talk about different ways to improve
your working memory depending on where
your Baseline working memory starts
which by the way turns out to be a
pretty good proxy for the levels of a
neuromodulator called dopamine within
the neural circuits that control working
memory so right now let's take a working
memory task we're going to do this
purely through audio form because I
realize some people are watching and
listening to this on YouTube and others
are just listening to this episode so
there are not going to be any visual
cues or slides that I present and that's
perhaps what distinguishes what we're to
do most from what would happen in a
laboratory typically in a laboratory
there would be some visual presentation
of what I'm about to say but here
because of the format that most of you
are consuming this information by we're
going to do this purely by Audio so the
first test of your working memory is
very simple I'm going to read off a
series of letters and your task is to
remember as many of those letters as you
can the first string of letters is J K k
z p
i okay just to make this really easy I'm
going to say it twice although typically
in a working memory task it would just
be said once but I'm going to make this
extra easy j k z p
i okay now you in your own head can try
and recite back those letters if you
like okay second string of letters r r o
m k l
e I'm going to make this extra simple
and do it again not typical for a
working memory task but there are some
working memory tasks where that happens
r o m k l
e okay now a third string of letters
this one's going to be a little bit
longer so queue up that working memory
and
attention w a c q v d
n I'll repeat that again w a c q v d
n how many of the letters I just read
can you remember okay so depending on
how many letters you can remember
perhaps you have a low moderate or high
degree of working
memory keep in mind that some of you are
perhaps doing other things you're
attending to driving or other tasks
within your home or your office and so
perhaps you weren't able to pay full
attention so there'll be some variation
there but nonetheless after reading each
of those strings of letters you were
asked to recall those letters in your
mind and if you wrote them down and
you're rereading them yes that's
cheating but how about this what if I
were to ask you now about the simplest
first string of letters the one that
consisted of only five letters how many
of you can remember any of those five
letters
now okay I can't hear you if you're
shouting them out uh I can't see you if
you're raising your hand but chances are
most of you have forgotten the first
series of letters even though it was
quite short and you could remember it
early on that ability to remember that
string of letters when you first heard
them and indeed I read them twice so I'd
be very surprised if any of you couldn't
remember that string of letters after
hearing them twice but I also read you
some other letters in the interim okay
so that now just a couple minutes later
I'm asking you to remember that first
string of five letters and assuming that
you didn't write it down you're not
cheating chances are you remember
anywhere from two to zero of those
letters in that first word which is a
perfect example of your working memory
nothing got committed to short-term much
less long-term memory rather your
working memory was able to work with
that information hold it in mind for
just as long as you thought you needed
to know that information but then thank
goodness that information was discarded
you didn't know that I was going to ask
you for that first string of letters
again after reading you the longer
string of letters but I did that
deliberately to show you how your
working memory works so in some sense
the working memory task is a bit unusual
in that it's a test of yes memory in the
very very short term but also a test of
your ability to forget to discard
information that's not critical and that
gets us back to the original definition
of working memory which is our ability
to attend to specific small batches of
information remember it for just as long
as we think we need to and then to
discard that information and by the way
if you want to know what those first
five letters were they were j k z p i
I'd like to take a brief moment and
thank one of our sponsors and that's ag1
ag1 is a vitamin mineral probiotic drink
that also contains adaptogens I started
taking ag1 way back in 2012 the reason I
started taking it and the reason I still
take it every day is that it ensures
that I meet all of my quotas for
vitamins and minerals and it ensures
that I get enough Prebiotic and
probiotic to support support gut health
now gut health is something that over
the last 10 years we realized is not
just important for the health of our gut
but also for our immune system and for
the production of neurotransmitters and
neuromodulators things like dopamine and
serotonin in other words gut health is
critical for proper brain functioning
now of course I strive to consume
healthy Whole Foods for the majority of
my nutritional intake every single day
but there are a number of things in ag1
including specific micronutrients that
are hard to get from Whole Foods or at
least in efficient quantities so ag1
allows me to get the vitamins and
minerals that I need probiotics
prebiotics the adaptogens and critical
micronutrients so anytime somebody asks
me if they were to take Just One
supplement what that supplement should
be I tell them ag1 because ag1 supports
so many different systems within the
body that are involved in mental health
physical health and performance to try
ag1 go to drink a1.com huberman and
you'll get a year supply of vitamin D3
K2 and five free travel packs of of ag1
again that's drink a1.com
huberman so now is where we talk a
little bit about the neural circuitry
and the neurochemistry of working memory
now it's important that we do this
because in a few minutes you're also
going to learn that people generally
fall into two broad bins of having a
high or low Baseline of a certain
neurochemical in the brain that affords
them either high or low working memory
capacity now in reality it's a
distribution in fact it's what we call a
normal distribution so it really isn't
two bins but during today's discussion
and in fact in a lot of laboratory
studies we can actually bin people into
these two groups the neural circuitry
underlying working memory involves a lot
of different brain locations that is a
lot of different neural networks
collaborating to create this thing we
call working memory however there are a
couple of key hubs that is locations
within the brain that are especially
important for working memory the ones
that I'd like to focus focus on today
involve the prefrontal cortex so this is
neural real estate that resides just
behind the forehead and the neurons in
the brain stem so further back in the
brain that manufacture dopamine and that
send their little wires that we call
axons up to the prefrontal cortex to
release dopamine dopamine is a
neuromodulator many people are familiar
with dopamine and familiar with it in
the context of motivation and drive
sometimes people mistakenly think it's
only involved in pleasure but dopamine
is involved in motivation and drive when
dopamine systems go Ary that is if their
levels get too high that can create
manic States it can create addictive
States when dopamine levels are too low
you can get movement challenges such as
in Parkinson's which is a deficit or a
literal destruction of the neurons that
manufacture dopamine there are a bunch
of different areas of the brain that
those dopamine neurons in the brain stem
project to but for right now we're going
to focus almost entirely on the dopamine
projections from the brain stem to the
prefrontal cortex which is called the
misoc cortical circuitry I'm not going
to get into the origins or the meaning
of the misoc cortical versus other
dopamine projection systems I did that
in a couple of episodes about ADHD and
attention and dopamine in particular and
you can find those at huberman lab.com
just put dopamine and circuits into the
search function and it will take you to
those particular time stamps where I
describe that but since we want to keep
things fairly top Contour at the level
of neural circuit here just know that
there are a bunch of neurons that
manufacture dopamine back in the brain
stem that send their axons those little
wires up to the prefrontal cortex and
that the amount of dopamine
released per unit time so in a certain
amount of time strongly dictates the
extent to which working memory capacity
is going to be high medium or low now I
want to be very clear because I'm going
to come back to this a little bit later
again and
again it is the case that when dopamine
levels are lower that is either there
are fewer neurons that have the
potential to release dopamine in the
frontal cortex or for whatever reason
less is being released in the frontal
cortex that working memory performance
tends to be lower as compared to
conditions where dopamine release or the
availability of dopamine is higher
however it is not the case that more
dopamine is always going to equate to
improved working memory this is so
important that I'm going to say it again
it is not always the case that
increasing the amount of dopamine
Transmission in the frontal cortex leads
to improvements in working memory there
is a specific criteria that allows us to
predict whether or not it will improve
or maintain or actually degrade working
memory performance so before you head to
the end of the podcast to try and figure
out ways to increase dopamine to improve
working memory please keep that fact in
mind don't just commit it to your
working memory commit it to your short
and long-term memory because that's very
important if your goal is to improve
your working memory with that said I do
want to describe just a little little
bit of research showing the relationship
between having a low working memory span
as it's called the ability to only
remember a few letters or numbers or
short batches of information as compared
to a high working memory span meaning
longer strings of letters longer strings
of numbers which of course in the real
world translates to being able to carry
out shorter versus longer action
sequences as described earlier in the
scenario where you're getting up in the
morning and you're making coffee and
you're heading out for run etc etc
people do differ in terms of their
working memory capacity and there's a
classic study done by kols and desposito
and colleagues this was published in
2008 where they had a way to label the
amount of dopamine that is available for
release in the frontal cortex in human
subjects they did this by the injection
of a specific Dy that Dy gets taken up
specifically by the neurons in the brain
that manufacture dopamine then they were
able to image the brains of those people
while those people were Wide Awake using
something called positron emission
tomorrow graphy again the specific tool
isn't necessarily important but since
some of you like to know and what they
found is that for people that had a high
working memory span that is could
remember long strings of numbers or
letters or other information they tended
to be the people that had more dopamine
available for release in the frontal
cortex either because they had more of
the dopamine neurons themselves or
similar number of neurons but those
neurons had more dopamine to release
okay and they also found the converse
individuals that had a low working
memory span and ability had less
dopamine available for release so that
establishes a correlation but it's not
causal a different study which is also a
classic was carried out by brazowy Brown
roswold and Goldman and this is a really
important study because in this study
they were able to introduce small
amounts of dopamine directly into the
cortex and evaluate working memory
capacity now anytime working memory test
is done the same pattern always emerges
this is regardless of any dopamine being
infused into the brain which is people
and animals for that matter are very
good at remembering short spans of
numbers letters or other types of
information so if you tell them one
thing like the letter a and then you ask
them do you remember the letter almost
everybody remembers that but if you give
them a string of 10 letters they
remember fewer of those 10 letters
that's sort of obvious but it's an
important point to emphasize nonetheless
and so there's a kind of a dropping off
curve of performance as one progresses
from fewer to Greater number of items to
be remembered in this study when
dopamine was introduced to the frontal
cortex the number of things that
individuals could remember simply
increased it was a very straightforward
result more dopamine introduced allowed
longer letter number and information
strings to be remembered and of course
forgotten because that's what working
memory involves remembering and then
discarding of information shortly
thereafter now the findings I just
described complement what I said before
which is the naturally occurring
experiment bring people into the lab
measure their working memory span look
at how much dopamine they make higher
dopamine better working memory lower
dopamine lower working
memory the experiment I just described
was one in which dopamine is introduced
showing that dopamine is very likely the
rate limiting or the capacity limiting
it's probably the better way to put it
the capacity limiting neurom modulator
for improving working memory that's a
fancy nerd speaker way of saying more
dopamine allows for better working
memory but a critical feature of this
experiment is that they did a number of
experiments where they didn't introduce
dopamine but instead they introduced
other neuromodulators to the prefrontal
cortex such as
norepinephrine or serotonin and the
interesting finding is that the addition
of norepinephrine or serotonin which of
course are other neuromodulators that
can change the firing patterns of
neurons in the prefrontal cortex but
elsewhere as well it's just that in this
case they were added to the prefrontal
cortex had no effect on working memory
it neither improved nor degraded working
memory when those neuromodulators were
introduced in other words dopamine and
perhaps only dopamine seems to be the
dominant neuromodulator for regulating
the degree that is whether or not you
have small medium or large amounts of
working memory capacity in the
prefrontal cortex and of course there
have been a bunch of other experiments
that are worth mentioning briefly in
this context such as taking people that
have a high working memory capacity and
indeed have their brains imaged and one
sees that they have high levels of
Baseline dopamine especially the
dopamine projecting to the prefrontal
cortex and then they're given a drug
that depletes dopamine within the
prefrontal cortex and their performance
drops and so what's so nice about the
literature around working memory is that
while I'm not covering all of that
literature exhaustively it all tends to
Jive it all points in a direction
whereby the levels of of dopamine being
released in the prefrontal cortex during
working memory tasks correlates very
strongly with capacity to perform
working memory tasks lower dopamine
lower working memory span as it's called
higher dopamine higher working memory
span okay so next we're going to do
another working memory task different
than the one we did earlier and we're
going to do that with a specific purpose
in mind which is for you to be able to
determine what your working memory
capacity is and by extension your
Baseline levels of dopamine or at least
the levels of dopamine that are likely
being released into your prefrontal
cortex while you do these working memory
tasks in other words we're going to try
and figure out whether or not you are of
the low medium or high working memory
capacity and of course we're doing that
in part to try and establish whether or
not you likely have low medium or high
amounts of dopamine available for
release in the prefrontal cortex of
course we're not putting you into a
positron Omission tomography scanning
device we aren't able to do that for
obvious reasons but keep in mind that
what we about to do is very similar and
in some cases identical to laboratory
studies where the researchers were
trying to determine what people's levels
of dopamine within these particular
neural networks we've been discussing
the misoc cortical pathway are likely to
be in other words performance on The
Working memory task that we are about to
do is a decent indication of what the
dopamine levels that are available for
release in your prefrontal cortex
perhaps might be now I say perhaps might
be because I don't want to cause any
unnecessary alarm if for instance you
fall into the low working memory span
group in fact if you fall into the low
working memory span group there are
actually some terrific tools that you
can use to improve dopamine Transmission
in those Pathways and improve your
working memory I also don't want people
to get the impression that somehow
performance on this working memory task
is reflective of some larger dopamine
issue in the brain and certainly it is
not I repeat it is not diagnostic of
Parkinson's or any kind of neurod deener
generative condition although I will say
that deficits in working memory are
common in patients with Parkinson for
obvious reasons those patients have
deficits in dopamine neurons not only
production but the number of dopamine
neurons it's one of the Hallmark
features of Parkinson's but also in
things like traumatic brain injury Etc
but the working memory task that you're
about to take when given to a general
population or a group of undergraduates
or you know so-called normals or typical
control subjects which all of you are
okay so unless you're dealing with with
a traumatic brain injury or you know you
have Parkinson's we know that the data
that you're going to get back right now
is very similar to the data that people
get back when they do these sorts of
studies in a laboratory that is it's
typical for some people to have a short
working memory span some people to have
a medium working memory span and some
people that have a high working memory
span and today we're actually just going
to divide into two bins short working
memory span and high working memory span
and we can have some degree of
confidence that correlates with the
amount of dopamine available for release
in the front Al cortex but and this is a
very important Point as we progress
along this discussion of working memory
the neural circuits dopamine Etc I want
to make clear something that I said
earlier which is that it is not the case
that increasing the amount of dopamine
that's available always increases
working memory spin in fact there's a
common circumstance whereby people with
a relatively High degree of working
memory capacity increase their dopamine
levels even further using pharmacology
or other methods that we'll discuss and
their per performance actually can
degrade okay so if any of that is
confusing now we'll make it all very
simple going forward so that if you
decide to implement any of the protocols
discussed in this episode that you are
aware of what you can expect and whether
or not you in the category of people
that should or perhap should not
incorporate those protocols okay let's
test your working memory again this time
the working memory task is going to be a
little bit different than the one you
did previously this working memory task
involves me reading six different
sentences to you and your job is to pay
attention to these six sentences because
you're going to be asked some
information about these sentences in a
few moments the first sentence is real
estate costs are going
up the second sentence is the Atlantic
Ocean is warm in
summer the third sentence is there's a
lot of interest now in electric
cars the fourth sentence is some
reptiles eat only one once a
year the fifth sentence is kids nowadays
look at screens more than 60% of their
Waking
Life and the sixth and final sentence is
football can mean different sports
depending on the
country okay so I read you six sentences
they were moderately long I confess your
job for the working memory task is now
to recall as many of the final words of
each of those sentences as you can I'll
give you a few moments to do that now
before I tell you what the final word of
each of those sentences actually is I
want to remind everybody that working
memory capacity follows a normal
distribution so some of you will be able
to remember the final word of perhaps
five or even six of those sentences
although I must say that is exceedingly
rare some of you are going to be able to
remember three to four of the final
words of those sentences and that's more
typical that actually represents the
average or the mean as we call it and
then fewer people although still many of
you will only be able to remember one or
two of the final words of those
sentences okay so now I'm assuming that
most of you have tried to call to memory
the final word of as many of those six
sentences as you can and maybe you've
written them down or you've typed them
into your phone or you have some record
of what you recall those six final words
of those sentences are now I'm going to
tell you the actual final word of each
of those sentences the final word of the
first sentence was up because as you may
recall the sentence was real estate
costs are going up the final word of the
second sentence was summer because the
sentence was the Atlantic Ocean is warm
in summer the final word of the third
sentence was Cars because the sentence
was there is a lot of interest in
electric cars the final word of the
fourth sentence was year because the
sentence was some reptiles eat only once
a year the final word of the fifth
sentence was life because the sentence
was kids nowadays look at screens more
than 60% of their Waking Life and the
final word of the sixth sentence was
country because the sentence was
football can mean different sports
depending on the country okay so be
honest with yourself and tell yourself
and you don't have to tell anyone else
if you don't want to how many of the
final words of those six sentences you
could remember correctly it's important
that you remember them correctly again
the number of words that you can recall
that is your working memory span is
going to vary from person to person but
we can take the normal distribution of
those scores and sort of draw a line
down the middle and say that if you
could remember three to six of the final
words of those sentences correctly
you're going to fall into the high
working memory span group whereas if you
could only remember one or two or maybe
zero of the final words of those six
sent
then you're going to be in the low
working memory span group again I don't
want to alarm anybody this doesn't mean
that you have any Global memory deficits
or dopamine deficits but it is important
especially if you plan to apply any of
the protocols to improve working memory
that you Faithfully that is you
accurately report your working memory
performance at least to yourself now as
you recall whether or not you have low
or high and here we are just binning
into low and high there's no medium
we've divided right at that line we're
saying if you can remember 3 to six
we're calling that high working memory
span at least for this discussion and if
you can remember fewer than three even
down to zero of the final words of those
sentences that's low working memory span
we're dividing it in two we divided you
into two groups and we do know when this
has been done in large numbers of human
subjects and some in some cases all of
those subjects have their brains imaged
for the amount of dopamine available for
release in their prefrontal cortex that
short workking memory span correlates
with lower amounts of dopamine whereas
higher working memory span or longer
working memory span whatever you want to
call it correlates with more dopamine
available for release in the prefrontal
cortex now this is where things get
really interesting and frankly really
exciting for everybody especially the
folks in the low working memory span
group work from martus bazito and
colleagues at UC Berkeley as well as
other Laboratories have explored the
consequences of increasing dopamine
levels in the brain of typical
populations of individuals so these are
not people with Parkinson's or TBI but
undergraduate students which we do
realize is not completely representative
of the quote unquote normal population
outside the university but also people
from the community so people who are not
University students and so on and the
ways that they've increased dopamine in
those individuals had tended to rely on
pharmacology so these are prescription
drugs that most often have been
developed for theat treat M of
Parkinson's in order to increase
dopamine levels but for some other
purposes as well drugs like
bromocryptine which we know are
so-called dopamine agonis and agonis is
a drug that has the consequence of
increasing the amount of a given
neurochemical in this case dopamine
whereas an antagonist is a drug that
either blocks or prevents or somehow
lowers the total available amount of a
certain chemical such as dopamine or
serotonin Etc so bromocryptine is a drug
that increases dopamine so when human
subjects came into a laboratory didn't
take any drug no bromocryptine yet and
of course they were being evaluated for
whether or not they were taking any meds
for ADHD their caffeine consumption Etc
there were certain rule-in and Rule outs
for that study but certainly people that
were taking any kind of prescription
medication for ADHD were not included in
the study or were eliminated from the
study because those drugs can indeed
increase dopamine as well as some other
neuromodulators such as norepinephrine
and epinephrine I covered all that in
two ADHD episodes that I did which again
you can find at hubman lab.com just go
to the search function put in ADHD in
any event in these studies they took
people that had not taken any drugs to
increase
dopamine had their working memory
measured very similarly to the way that
you measured your working memory a few
minutes ago with the six sentence
business that we did and then they took
bromocryptine and they either took a low
a moderate or high dose of bromocryptine
and 90 minutes later they took a working
memory task and what was observed was
very interesting you can probably
predict what it is based on everything
I've set up until now individuals that
initially had low Baseline levels of
dopamine and therefore shorter working
memory span so they only remembered zero
to about three of the final words of
that six sentence
series their performance significantly
improved they were able to remember four
and in some cases up to six the final
words of those sentences now that is in
complete agreement with everything we
set up until now simply says that
dopamine is important for working memory
if you start off with lower dopamine
stores or dopamine availability for
releasing the prefrontal cortex lower
working memory performance increase
dopamine through ingestion of
bromocryptine which is this dopamine
Agonist all of the circuit changes that
we want and would expect to improve
working memory occur and indeed working
memory improves okay very
straightforward
that's interesting but the even more
interesting part of the study is that
individuals that already had high
working memory span when they took
bromocryptine at a low or a moderate
dose their working memory did not
increase further now if somebody was
already getting six of the final words
of those six sentences well then of
course they couldn't improve their
performance anymore but many of the
people in the high working memory span
group of course only remembered four in
some cases three typically it'll be four
five or six of the final words of those
sentences when they took bromocryptine
at low or moderate doses their working
memory did not improve significantly
there was either no change or a very
modest change and here's where things
get really interesting when individuals
who already had a high working memory
span took the highest dose of
bromocryptine and by the way studies
verified that the amount of dopamine
available indeed increased so that was
important to do and they did that well
their working memory performance
actually
decreased such that now they had a short
or a low working memory span so what
this tells us is that the relationship
between dopamine and working memory
follows an inverted u-shaped function so
imagine a u and then just flip it over
meaning if you have low dopamine
availability in the prefrontal cortex
working memory span is short as you
increase that amount working memory
becomes greater but if you increase the
amount of dopamine in the prefrontal
cortex too much working memory span
actually drops significantly below the
Baseline that you started with now this
is important for a number of reasons not
the least of which is the known
relationship between working memory and
attention now this is very important to
understand in the context of ADHD but
also for people who don't have ADHD and
are struggling to maintain focus and
attention and carry out working memory
tasks throughout their normal everyday
life not in the laboratory but just
moving through life because these days
we hear a lot a lot a lot about people
struggling with focus and attention
perhaps we don't know perhaps in part
due to overuse of smartphone social
media Etc although there's not yet a
direct causal relationship that's been
established the data that are emerging
suggests that indeed overuse of those
things can cause problems but regardless
of the source there does seem to be more
ADHD both in kids and in adults and
subclinical challenges in focus and
attention and here's where things get
really interesting as it relates to the
neural circuitry work from desposito and
colleagues and other Laboratories as
well have shown using the similar
Paradigm that I described before giving
people drugs to increase their Baseline
levels of dopamine above their initial
starting point of short or long-term
memory span capacity and then had people
can perform different types of working
memory tasks that tap into two different
aspects of attention in working memory
up until now we've been talking about
working memory it's kind of just one
thing but working memory actually
involves two things or at least two
things the first is that in order to
carry out a working memory task into to
attend to something to really focus we
need the ability to rule out distractors
we need to be able to not pay attention
to things that would otherwise distract
Us in addition to that we need to be
able to switch from one context to the
next right making the cup of coffee to
putting on one shoes and heading out the
door and in some cases layering
different contexts together talking on
the phone while tying one shoes and so
on and so forth what this work shows us
is that the ability to task switch and
context switch that is to shift around
what it is that we're paying attention
to and interleave different things that
we're paying attention to something
that's so critical for moving through
our daily lives is largely dependent on
the dopamine projections to a structure
in the brain called the basil ganglia
which is a structure I've talked about
before on this podcast but if you didn't
hear about it we can just broadly Define
this structure as being involved in
movement generation and stopping
movement generation in fact it's often
discussed as the neural circuitry that
generates go as in do commands and noo
don't do commands so the basil ganglia
are involved in task switching and they
involved in task switching in part by
sending certain commands to go do
certain things and no go to not do other
things okay task switching stop doing
this start doing that start doing that
stop doing this and sometimes to varying
extents right I mean we could take any
real world scenario of tying one shoes
while talking on the phone and we could
micro analyze it in the context of this
but I think uh if you think about it
just a little bit you understand that in
order to perform daily task we need to
be able to task switch and that's not
always a start one task end start a new
task end often times we're interleaving
different tasks to varying degrees now
the other aspect of working memory and
attention is to eliminate distractions
to not pay attention to the irrelevant
stuff in one's environment or even the
irrelevant stuff on your own body like
you can't get distracted by you know a
button that you know might be only
partially buttoned or maybe some little
something on your sleeve if you're
trying to do something else at that
moment okay and people with ADHD and
people who have subclin clinical
challenges and focus really have a hard
time with this right you know the the
sort of stereotype is you know the oh
look a squirrel that whole thing but
really this typically exists as a more
subtle and challenging phenomenon for
people where they either can't remember
what they were doing or they're simply
drawn down different trajectories
different thought trajectories or action
trajectories and then they have a hard
time making it back to the original
thing that they were trying to focus on
and we know based on these studies of
dopamine and neuroimaging that
eliminating distractors is largely the
consequence of dopamine neurons
projecting to the prefrontal cortex okay
now why am I telling you all this neural
circuitry stuff well yes there are a
bunch of studies showing that if you
selectively activate the neurons that
send dopamine into the basil ganglia you
improve Tas switching ability without an
improved ability to rule out distractors
or if you selectively increase the
amount of dopamine from neurons
projecting the prefrontal cortex that
you're able to selectively improve the
elimination of dist tractors without
improving task switching ability for
practical purposes in this discussion we
want to pay careful attention to whether
or not the data tell us that those
particular protocols those particular
approaches are globally increasing
dopamine that is increasing the activity
of dopamine neurons projecting to the
basil ganglia and the prefrontal cortex
or selectively to the basil ganglia or
selectively to the prefrontal cortex and
what I can tell you now is that
fortunately there are several prot some
of which are behavioral some of which
involve specific over-the-counter
supplements and some of which involve
prescription pharmacology that can tap
into each of these systems independently
as well as globally increased dopamine
to improve focus and working memory at
large I'd like to take a quick break to
acknowledge our sponsor element element
is an electrolyte drink that has
everything you need and nothing you
don't that means zero sugar and the
appropriate ratios of the electrolytes
sodium magnesium and potassium and that
correct ratio of electrolytes is
extremely important because every cell
in your body but especially your nerve
cells your neurons relies on
electrolytes in order to function
properly so when you're well hydrated
and you have the appropriate amount of
electrolytes in your system your mental
functioning and your physical
functioning is improved I drink one
packet of element dissolved in about 16
to 32 ounces of water when I wake up in
the morning as well as while I exercise
and if I've sweat a lot during that
exercise I often will drink a third
element packet dissolved in about 32
ounces of water after I exercise element
comes in a variety of different flavors
all of which I find really tasty I like
the Citrus I like the watermelon I like
the raspberry frankly I can't pick just
one it also comes in chocolate and
chocolate mint which I find tastes best
if they are put into water dissolved and
then heated up I tend to do that in the
winter months because of course you
don't just need hydration on hot days
and in the summer and spring months but
also in the winter when the temperatures
are cold and the environment tends to be
dry if if you'd like to try element you
can go to drink element spelled lm.com
huberman to try a free sample pack again
that's drink element.com
huberman okay so let's talk about
protocols to improve working memory
specifically by way of changing levels
of dopamine in the brain now I've
discussed dopamine many times before in
this podcast in fact we have entire
episodes devoted to optimizing and
regulating dopamine and of course
dopamine comes up within the context of
the ADHD episodes and episodes as well
and again if you have specific questions
about dopamine or any other topic for
that matter if you go to huberman
lab.com that website has been engineered
so that you can put one word such as
dopamine but also multiple keywords so
perhaps dopamine exercise or dopamine
cold plunge Etc into the search function
and it will take you to the specific
timestamps of multiple episodes where
those topics were discussed as well as
newsletters where some of that
information has been condensed into
short PDF form Etc so we certainly are
going going to cover some material about
improving dopamine for sake of improving
working memory now but if you're
generally interested in the science and
pharmacology of dopamine and protocols
to modulate dopamine levels all of that
can be found at huberman lab.com okay so
let's say you have a short working
memory span or a moderate working memory
span and you want to experiment with
increasing levels of dopamine for sake
of improving working memory now there
are a lot of different ways that one
could imagine doing that let's start
with the behavioral tools known to
increase dopamine stores that is shown
in peer-reviewed studies to increase
dopamine stores within certain circuits
of the brain that are relevant for
working memory performance and the
protocol that immediately leaps to mind
is the use of certain non-sleep deep
rest protocols now non-sleep deep rest
or nsdr is actually a term that I coined
because there is a practice that's been
established for many hundreds of years
called Yoga Nidra which actually means
yoga sleep whereby individuals
potentially you if you decide to do them
lie down listen to to a script that is
listen to an audio script which
generally instructs you to do long
exhale breathing to deliberately relax
your musculature of your face and of
your body and Yoga Nidra typically also
involves doing certain intentions and
the instruction always given at the
beginning of Yoga Nidra is that you
should try to not fall asleep now some
people sometimes fall asleep some people
don't fall asleep but the idea and there
are data to support that Yoga Nidra puts
people into kind of a shallow pattern of
sleep um certainly not deep sleep s and
not rapid eye movement sleep but it's a
very interesting and unusual brain state
for which we're starting to understand
more and actually I have some plans in
the not too distant future to
collaborate with Matthew Walker the
author of the book why we sleep and some
other colleagues to try and figure out
what exact patterns of neural activity
are taking place in the brain and rest
of nervous system during Yoga Nidra and
this similar protocol which I call
nonsleep deep rest the difference
between Yoga Nidra and non-sleep deep
rest is that nonsleep deep rest doesn't
include any of the intentions and
removes a lot of the kind of opaque or
sometimes called mystical language from
the protocol now a great thing is that
yoga needra scripts or protocols as well
as nsdr scripts or Protocols are
available totally zero cost you can find
them certainly on apps like waking up
but also on YouTube for instance if you
put nsdr and my last name there's a
10-minute nsdr script there there are a
lot of yoga NRA scripts if you prefer a
female voice there are a lot of
different excellent female voices out
there one in particular particular that
I like very much is Kelly boy first name
Kelly last name b y s she has both yoga
NRA and ndr scripts of various durations
of anywhere from 8 minutes all the way
out to I believe 45 minutes why am I
telling you all this well there have
been several studies but in particular
one and I do realize we're talking about
only one study but the results are
really intriguing as it relates to what
we're talking about today in this study
they had individuals do effectively an
nsdr protocol they call it yoganidra and
the protocol they used was essentially a
yoga Nedra script they had people lie
down and listen to a yoga Nedra script
and to perform yoga Nedra and they
evaluated the amount of dopamine
available within the brain both prior to
and after performing this yoga NRA
script and what they discovered was that
after performing a Yoga Nidra protocol
the Baseline levels of dopamine that is
the amount of dopamine available in the
basil ganglia and a few other structures
of the human brain of course these are
humans was increased by as much as
60% as compared to individuals that did
a different protocol not yoganidra not
nsdr now did that study evaluate lots of
different durations of yoga Nedra AKA
nstr no they looked at fairly long hour
plus Yoga Nidra sessions however there's
some other data that have explored Yoga
Nidra AKA
nstr in the context of cognitive
performance and a few other
circumstances all of which point to the
fact that cognitive performance and in
particular cognitive performance tasks
that have a working memory element to
them so they weren't the exact working
memory task that you did earlier but
they have a working memory element to
them that is subjects had to keep
certain small batches of information in
mind and then discard that information
in order to be able to perform the task
well all of those show significant
improvements in task performance so
while something like nsdr or Yoga Nidra
might sound kind of mystical or kind of
you know wishy-washy or I guess as the
kids say weak sauce uh to some of you it
is anything but weak sauce it is really
powerful stuff and it's powerful stuff
as it relates to the very neurochemicals
and neuros circuits that are involved in
working memory so if I were to take a
step back and just say okay what are
some zeroc cost very low if any risk
protocols that one could perform in
order to improve dopamine levels without
having to ingest anything take anything
and really do much of anything at all
except lie there do this progressive
muscle relaxation there are a few other
things involved in nsdr as well which
you'll learn if you decide to try them
and improve or increase the levels of
dopamine availability in the brain
significantly well then nsdr and Yoga
Nidra really are the first line tools if
one wants to do that I think it's
reasonable to say that and as I
mentioned before there's no reason to
think that there's any risk of doing
nstr yoga NRA you know provide that
you're lying down in a safe place as
opposed to like in the middle of the
road or something but assuming you do it
in a safe location I would encourage you
to try it for really for 20 to 30
minutes when you first explore it
perhaps you do longer although I
personally have a hard time doing long
yoga needer scripts regularly a full
hour is a big commitment I don't
generally have that much time I often
will do a 10-minute nsdr have there been
brain Imaging experiments done for each
and all of these yoga needra scripts to
determine the amount or if there's any
dopamine increase within the brain no
but I think that we can safely
extrapolate from that wonderful study
out of Scandinavia that showed that when
human subjects do this yoga NRA protocol
that there's a significant increase in
Baseline dopamine levels within key
neural structures that relate to working
memory now many of you have perhaps
heard that getting in a cold plunge or
taking a cold shower or provided you can
do it safely getting into a cold ocean
or a cold lake can significantly maybe
even double or even triple your
circulating dopamine levels and indeed
that is true it has been shown that when
people get into cold water typically up
to their neck and that cold water by the
way can range in temperature anywhere
from low 40s to low 60s depending on how
long you stay in that there is a
significant increase in the so-called
circulating catac colomines what are the
catac colomines the catamin are dopamine
norepinephrine and epinephrine now the
evidence for the catac colomine increase
in response to cold water mainly stems
from two studies and in particular one
and in that particular study they had
people get into I wouldn't say super
cold water it was in the low 60° and by
the way I'm speaking in Fahrenheit here
and they had those human subjects
submerged in water up to their neck I
think they actually had them sitting in
lawn chairs on the bottom of a pool uh
but again their heads were above water
so they could breathe and they stayed in
for quite a long while you know 45
minutes or longer and it was observed
that there was a big big statistically
significant increase in epinephrine
norepinephrine in dopamine that lasted
several hours or more this is one of the
reasons why if you've ever done
deliberate cold exposure as it's called
it often is uncomfortable when you get
in but then when you get out you feel
different you feel really good in most
cases provided if you're me you take a
warm shower afterwards yes I like to do
that I realize if you want to increase
your metabolism perhaps it's better to
not warm up afterwards I like a nice
warm shower or to get in the sauna
afterwards that's just me but
nonetheless deliberate cold exposure
clearly induces a state shift of mind
and body that most people provided they
do it correctly and they don't go into
water that's far too cold for them for
too long they report as pleasant and I
think it's reasonable to assume that
some of that is the consequence of these
increases in catac colomines which is
why many people opt for a cold shower
which if you're me cold shower followed
by a warmer or hot shower or a cold
Plunge in the morning or maybe even just
once or twice a week many people like
them typically people like getting out
of them and the feeling that they have
after they do them although some of you
sickos really like the feeling of
getting in and being it but not me the
point here is that if we were to take a
look at the landscape of zeroc cost
behavioral Tools in fact behavioral
tools that could potentially save you
money meaning reduce your heating bill
that are known to increase the very
neurochemicals AKA dopamine that are
involved and improving working memory I
think it's reasonable to assume that a
cold shower about 30 to 60 minutes prior
to doing any kind of working memory task
or any kind of activity that would
require increased Focus could be okay we
don't know this specific Studies have
not been done but could be in theory it
makes sense mechanistically it's
logically
sound could be done after deliberate
cold exposure and indeed many people
report not just feeling a bit of you
know mild Euphoria or feeling good after
deliberate cold exposure but also an
increased capacity to focus in fact so
much so that a lot of people who do
deliberate cold exposure say that they
don't require as much caffeine in order
to maintain their alertness and energy
which shouldn't be surprising to us at
all right I mean it's increasing cacola
means we know this so that's another
protocol that you could explore as well
is there an important difference or not
between deliberate cold exposure done by
cold shower or deliberate cold exposure
in a cold plunge or the ocean frankly
there haven't been a lot of studies
comparing those but I think it stands to
reason that if you have access to a cold
plunge or a cold body of water that you
can safely get into up to your neck for
30 seconds to a minute if it's 50° or
less right if you get in colder water we
know for instance if you get into say 45
Dee water and you only get in for 30
seconds you're going to get a big
increase in the catacol amines perhaps
as big as the catacol amine increase
that you would get from being in 60°
water for 45 minutes most people don't
have 45 minutes to sit around in water
up to their neck so most people opt for
30 seconds to as much as 3 minutes
deliberate cold exposure in a shower or
cold plunge or other body of water again
only do this if you can do it safely
never ever please for the love of God
please never ever do any kind of
hyperventilation breathing or breath
holding while doing deliberate cold
exposure because you can pass out you
can die don't combine breath work and
deliberate cold exposure just don't
separate those two things completely
okay but deliberate coal exposure we
know is a very reliable way to increase
the catacol amines which includes
dopamine so if you want to explore
deliberate cold exposure protocols get
into the Nuance of temperature and
duration Etc you can find that
completely zero cost go to hubman
lab.com go to the menu tab scroll down
to newsletter and go to the cold
exposure news letter where it details
all of that in short PDF form now some
of you are probably asking hey what if I
was in the high or long working memory
span group I ought to have high Baseline
levels of dopamine should I not do Yoga
Nidra or nsdr should I not do deliberate
cold exposure well there you're just
going to have to experiment again
there's essentially zero risk to doing
yoganidra nsdr as I mentioned before
deliberate cold exposure there's always
some risk getting into water cold water
people always want to know how cold well
the newsletter gets to this but I'll
just tell you right now as well the
ideal temperature is the temperature
that you can safely get into and stay in
for a duration of 30 seconds to 3
minutes before getting out some people
op to go longer but I think 30 seconds
to 3 minutes is a good duration to work
with for most people especially if
you're going to do it frequently so the
temperature should be safe for you to
stay in for that duration but
uncomfortable enough that there's some
impulse to want to get out that you have
to of work to stay in there that you
have to kind of overcome that adrenaline
release and the impulse to get out okay
so for some people that's going to be
45° for some people be 40° depends on
how cold adapted you are depends on how
rested you are there is no specific
temperature you have to really gauge for
yourself and so airor on the side of
caution and you can experiment provided
you experiment within the margins of
safety so if you found during the
working memory task that you took today
that you have a very good working memory
I don't think there's any reason to
avoid yoganidra nsdr and deliberate cold
exposure in fact there may be reasons to
increase your dopamine and other catacol
amines by way of nsdr Yoga Nidra
deliberate cold exposure perhaps for
working memory performance maybe it
could increase
further perhaps it would decrease
performance in which case there you got
your answer you don't have to do those
protocols again and you certainly
wouldn't want to do them before anything
that involves a lot of working memory
and attention but of course those
protocols have other benefits as well so
there's no reason to avoid them entirely
just perhaps avoid them within the
context of trying to improve working
memory however if you're somebody that
has challenges with working memory
challenges with attention challenges
with Focus well then I think that the
protocols I've been talking about up
until now would be an excellent first
foray into the sorts of things that you
could do to increase dopamine and of
course those other catacol amines as a
way to see whether or not it augments
your focus and attention and working
memory capacity now some of you are
probably shouting shouting shouting what
about exercise does an exercise increase
dopamine it does yes there are other
things that increase dopamine it's not
just exercise there are activities that
increase dopamine some people are saying
wait doesn't playing video games
increase dopamine sex increases dopamine
chocolate increases dopamine yes yes
indeed those things can increase
dopamine what's interesting and
important about the protocols I've been
talking about however nsdr yoga Nedra
deliberate cold exposure is not just
that they increase dopamine but the
duration over which they increase
dopamine okay this is very important if
you want to understand more about the
relationship between dopamine spikes as
they're called and dopamine Baseline and
why I'm emphasizing these tools that
cause large longlasting increases in
Baseline dopamine check out the episodes
I did on optimizing dopamine we've got a
link to them in the show note captions
now before I talk about other ways to
increase dopamine for sake of improving
working memory things like
over-the-counter supplements like El
tyrosine makuna pururin things like that
I do briefly want to mention and I
promise briefly I know sometimes I say
briefly and then I spend 20 minutes
telling you about something but very
briefly I just want to spend two minutes
telling you about protocols that we do
not yet know whether or not they
increase dopamine levels but we do know
that they improve working memory because
after all this episode is about working
memory not just about dopamine in
working memory it has been shown that
the use of binaural beats okay binaural
beats being the presentation or the
listening to sounds of different
frequencies in the two ears typically by
headphones I think that's been shown to
work best and there's a subtraction
between the two frequencies such that
the brain tends to entrain or start to
follow a particular frequency within not
the entire brain but certain neural
circuits so if you've heard of say 15
Hertz binaural beats or 40 Herz binural
beats that doesn't mean that you listen
to a 15 Hertz sound or a 40 HZ sound you
listen to two different frequencies of
sound right Hertz is just a measurement
of sound frequency in each of the two
ears and then the difference between
them is 40 Herz or 15 Hertz and there
are several studies that show not
enormous okay I want to be clear small
to moderate improvements in working
memory performance but in some cases
significant Improvement and I'll provide
a link to these two papers in the show
note captions but I'll just briefly
describe them by way of their title and
their major conclusions the first is a
study entitled the effects of binaural
and monoral beat stimulation on
cognitive functioning in subjects with
different levels of emotionality a
really interesting study published in
2019 it was a relatively small number of
subjects only 24 participants 16 males
eight males between 19 and 31 years old
listen to these 40 Herz binaural beats
and by the way it's very easy easy to
find apps and other sources of 40 HZ
binaural beats at zero cost or nominal
cost out there um you would simply look
for 40 HZ binormal beats and looked at
performance on working memory tasks as
well as some other cognitive tasks and
found in some cases a small to moderate
but significant Improvement in cognitive
performance on working memory tasks the
aspect of the study looking at
emotionality did not find a significant
effect so it doesn't seem that
emotionality uh impacts things there but
nonetheless that study plus the other
one entitled the effect of binaural
beats on visual spatial working memory
and cortical connectivity this was a
study published in
2016 found generally something similar
in this case they were using 15 Herz
binaural beats and here I'm I'm
paraphrasing produced network activity
characteristic of high information
transfer with consistent connection
strengths what they're really talking
about is changes in neural activity
patterns within the brain that led to or
at least were correlated with with
improvements on visual spatial working
memory visual spatial working memory
tasks are different than the working
memory tasks that you performed earlier
visual spatial working memory tasks
involve the cognitive generation that is
within your head of the so-called Visos
spatial sketch pad so it's this idea
that you see something and then you got
of sketch it out in your mind you have
to know the relationships between things
in space pay attention to what they are
keep those in mind again because it's
working memory just as long as it's
necessary to perform a task that's what
viso spatial working memory is as you
can imagine it translates to an enormous
number of everyday activities required
for focus and attention and learning and
performance and indeed 15 Herz binaural
beats was able to produce a small but
significant Improvement in that sort of
working memory task so I want to
emphasize again we don't know the
relationship between binaural beats and
dopamine at least not from these studies
but I felt I'd be remiss if I didn't
mention these two studies that show that
40 Herz binaural beats 15 Herz binaural
beats can indeed improve working memory
performance and in these sorts of
scenarios individuals are listening to
the binaural beats while they are doing
the working memory task and in some
cases before they are doing the working
memory task either seems to work it
depends on the study there a bunch of
other studies but I thought I'd mention
binaural beats because I know a number
of people are interested in them again
non-pharmacologic zero cost because you
can find tools for bormal Beat
Generation zero cost out there
approaches to improving working memory
okay what about over-the-counter
compounds that are known to increase
circulating dopamine that can
potentially improve working memory and
that indeed have been shown in
peer-reviewed studies to improve working
memory by way of increasing circulating
presumably brain levels of dopamine well
I can think of two specific categories
of supplements that is over-the-counter
compounds that at least at this point in
time are legal in the United States that
can increase dopamine levels those two
are El tyrosine which is an amino acid
precursor to dopamine and Muna purines
which is a believe it or not it's the uh
a velvety Bean or the outer component of
this velvety Bean that contains or is
equivalent to
99% lopa L Doopa is a key component in
the biochemical Cascade leading to the
production of dopamine in fact lopa is
often prescribed for Parkinson patients
as a means to increase their dopamine
levels there are at least three studies
that I am aware of of the use of Muna
purines to increase dopamine for the
treatment of Parkinson's in other words
Muna purines increases dopamine levels
and yes it has been shown to improve
some of those symptoms of Parkinson's
patients we're not talking about
treatment of Parkinson's today I want to
caution people against any sort of use
of supplements to treat Parkinson's or
other conditions without consulting your
doctor all right that's very very
critical to point out if we're talking
about ways to increase dopamine for sake
of improving working memory by way of
supplementation I think we should start
with El tyos because El tyrosine unlike
Muna Pines is a bit further up actually
it's way further up the biochemical
Cascade leading to dopamine production
however it has been shown in several
studies that El tyrosine supplementation
can indeed increase dopamine and
moreover and here I'm quoting the title
of a study published in 1999 which I
realized is a few years back but of
course there's some excellent studies
from a few years back or more tyrosine
improves working memory in a
multitasking environment now this
particular study from Thomas at all has
some interesting aspects and some
aspects that made me go a little bit
wide-eyed but not necessarily wide-eyed
because the results are so dramatic in
fact when one looks at all of the data
in this paper what you find is that
supplementing with El tyrosine as they
did in this study did indeed lead to
improvements in working memory under
multitask conditions as the title
suggests those improvements were
significant but they weren't enormous
okay they were statistically significant
but they were not enormous increases now
what was enormous and the reason I got
wide-eyed and still get wide-eyed is
that the dosages of of tyrosine used in
the study are really big they had
subjects take 150 milligrams per
kilogram of el crystalline tyrosine I
had them take it in applesauce for
whatever reason or Placebo and they did
a number of different control conditions
to make sure that whatever effects of el
tyrosine they observed were in fact due
to El tyrosine supplementation why am I
going wide-eyed When I See This 150
milligrams per Kil
of tyrosine well I weigh 220 lb that's
about 100 kg so if I weigh 100 kilg and
it's 150 milligram for every kilogram
that means that if I were a subject in
the study that they would give me 15,000
milligram that is 15 gram of el tyrosine
prior to doing these cognitive tasks now
15 grams of tyrosine to me seems like a
very very high dose and I frankly can't
in good conscience recommend that why
well maybe I'm just hypers sensitive to
El tyroine but I've taken 1,000 or500
milligrams of el tyrosine and I've
definitely experienced an increase in
alertness from taking 1.5 gram not 15
1.5 grams of el tyrosine and in fact at
a subjective level I can feel a
meaningful increase in alertness and
focus from 500 milligrams of el tyrosine
so I can't in good conscience suest that
people replicate the exact do protocols
within the study nonetheless the study
as the title suggests shows that
supplementing with El tyrosine can
indeed increase working memory capacity
especially in a multitasking environment
which in many ways carries over to the
sorts of requirements for working memory
and attention capacity to get through
life in a very focused for lack of a
better word way in a very regimented do
this do that task switch multiple things
inter Lea that's what moving through
one's day or at least work day or
anything that requires cognition and
focus entails so first of all I'll just
say what I always say when discussing
any kind of compound or prescription
drug never add or remove any supplement
from your supplement regimen if you have
one without consulting with your health
provider first to make sure that you are
safe to take that particular supplement
now many Physicians MDS are not familiar
with most supplements so you'll probably
need to bring some literature um to the
phone call or to the visit but of course
there are many Healthcare Providers
including some MDS that are open to
supplementation especially these days um
as supplements have become uh I would
say generally more accepted I mean there
are certain ones like vitamin D3 that
and fish oils and things like that that
are more common than El tyrosine but
there are many Physicians who are open
to discussions about supplements such as
El tyrosine if you know that you can
supplement with El tyrosine safely and
you opt to do so what dosages would you
potentially take well here we have to
look at the dosages used in these
studies I think it's only fair it's only
safe that we acknowledge that these dose
just are really really high and I think
the logical the safe thing to do would
be to start with the minimal effective
dose so if you weigh 50
kilograms rather than start right off
with you know the equivalent dosage to
this study maybe you start with 250
milligrams of el tyrosine if you weigh a
bit more like me or 100 kgrs or 75 kilg
maybe you take 500 milligrams of el
tyrosine and see whether or not you
experience a significant effect on
working memory attention and performance
so the idea here is to establish the
minimal effective dose I should also
point out that some people not all but
some people experience a bit of a crash
after El tyrosine supplementation such
that they feel more alert more focused
better ability to perform working memory
tasks move about their day but then
three or four hours later experience
kind of a drop so you need to be mindful
of that in fact you need to be mindful
of any kind of pharmacology where you're
increasing dopamine this is one of the
reasons why I like the behavioral
protocols that we talked about earlier
because they're known to create big but
long lasting and slowly tapering off
increases in dopamine and other catacol
amines now for those who are curious
about and perhaps even want to try Muna
purines please absolutely talk to your
doctor first Muna perin is essentially
the equivalent of lopa lopa is a
prescription drug as I mentioned before
and Muna perin potently increases
dopamine what dosages of Muna Pines can
increase dopamine well typically in
studies of Parkinson's patients but also
studies exploring typical people who
don't have Parkinson's in tasks or in
sports performance have explored
anywhere from 1 to 5 gr of Muna purins
Muna purin again is a very potent way to
increase dopamine and here if your
healthc care provider approves it and
you decide to try it I would suggest
starting with a very very low dose again
to to find the minimal effective dose so
maybe even just 500 milligrams not even
going to the one gram dose maybe even
250 milligrams and really evaluating how
much Muna pance can produce a meaningful
impact on working memory and attention
for you so Muna pan is kind of a bridge
between over-the-counter supplements and
prescription drugs I say it's a bridge
because it is Oho similar to that
prescription drug L Doopa and of course
there is a long list of prescription
drugs that are known to be dopamine
Agonist several of which many of which
in fact have been shown to improve
working memory you already learned about
one of those before which is
bromocryptine now you need a
prescription from a physician to get
bromocryptine but bromocryptine we know
based on that work from desposito
colleagues that I talked about earlier
increases dopamine it does so in about
90 minutes it achieves Peak levels of
dopamine about 90 minutes and improves
working memory in individuals that start
off with a low working memory span and
we know from neuroimaging those are the
individuals with lower Baseline levels
of dopamine so should you run out and
ask your doctor for bromocryptine maybe
most doctors won't prescribe
bromocryptine for that reason I should
mention that work from desposito lab and
other Laboratories has shown that one of
the Hallmark features of traumatic brain
injury especially frontal lobe injury as
well as certain neurod degenerative
conditions like Parkinson's but other
forms of dementia as well as ADHD
involve deficits in working memory and
attention which makes sense given what
we know about the symptoms of those
conditions and that bromocryptine has
been prescribed off Lael for the
treatment of those conditions to some
degree of success however those are off
Lael circumstances right now as far as I
know bromocryptine is not prescribed
specifically for those conditions at a
kind of whole population level it's not
one of the drugs on the lookup table for
ADHD or TBI but certain well-informed
neurologists and Physicians do prescribe
it for that reason there are other
dopamine agonists that are relevant in
this context the ones that I think most
of you will be familiar with are the
drugs that increase dopamine and
norepinephrine for the treatment of ADHD
and I did an entire episode of The
hubman Lab podcast about those compounds
things like adderal things like rellin
which by by the way is quite different
than Aderall in terms of how much
dopamine relative to norepinephrine it
causes the increase of I cover all that
in those episodes again you can simply
go to hubman lab.com put ADHD Aderall or
ADHD riddlin and I talk about other
things as well I also took a little bit
about modafanil which is a entirely
different category of drug known to
improve cognitive performance in some
cases in ADHD but in everybody so there
are a lot of different drugs that can
improve working memory most of those do
so by increasing transmission of
dopamine or availability of dopamine
somehow changing dopamine levels in the
brain by increasing them so if you're
somebody that has challenges with
working memory focus and attention
please see those episodes and please
talk to your doctor about potentially
using pharmacology to increase dopamine
however and this is very important many
people who have challenges with Focus
attention and working memory and fall
under the category of subclinical levels
of ADHD and even some individuals with
88 she young and old manage their
symptoms and in some cases improve their
focus through the use of Behavioral
tools nutritional tools supplement based
Tools in ways that either allow them to
reduce their total prescription drug
dosages and in some cases come off them
entirely now I am definitely not saying
that people should come off those drugs
entirely and in fact I want to take a
really firm stand here because I know
this is a bit controversial but I'm just
going to tell you having evaluated the
whole literature several times over now
I do think I personally believe that
there is a strong case for certain
children and adults to take these
compounds that increase dopamine and
epinephrine yes those compounds are
different forms of amphetamine but those
compounds we know can increase
neuroplasticity the rewiring ltp LTD Etc
within the neural circuits that control
Focus attention and working memory and
so they do have their place for certain
individuals we don't want to rule those
out are they over prescribed my feeling
is that yes they are probably
overprescribed however there are a
number of individuals that strongly
benefit from them as well so if you are
going to explore the use of those
compounds for sake of improving working
memory certainly if you're going to
explore them for sake of improving
working memory and focus in young kids
please please please talk to your
physician because they're prescription
drugs you would need to talk to a
physician anyway but regardless of
whether or not you're trying to improve
focus and working memory in a child in
an adult someone with TBI someone with
Parkinson's
I think it stands to reason that you
would arrive to that conversation with
some knowledge of not just the
prescription drugs that are potentially
available but also some of the
supplement based tools some of the
behavioral tools because as we know and
as a good friend of mine who's an
excellent physician says Better Living
Through Chemistry still requires Better
Living meaning yes prescription drugs
can have a positive impact on these
aspects of brain function in a way that
can really improve lives but that
behavioral tools also work in fact they
can collaborate in a very synergistic
way to increase the amount of
neuroplasticity in the relevant circuits
so I'm of the mind and I think more and
more people out there I like to think
are of the mind that behaviors nutrition
supplement based tools and prescription
drugs all can have their place to
varying degrees depending on the
circumstances and the individual okay so
today we talked about working memory
this incredible capacity of our brain in
fact a specific set of brain circuits
designed for us to absorb absorb
information that is perceived in our
environment use the relevant parts and
then Chuck it just get rid of it forget
it so very different than short and
long-term memory which we also discussed
and we talked about a few of the
mechanisms as well I think you'll agree
that working memory is one of the more
incredible aspects to brain function I
mean if you think about this is a set of
neural circuits that engage the same
algorithm over and over in different
context in order for us to be able to
navigate new environments familiar
environments to interleave different
activities these different strategies to
task switch to rule out distractors it's
oh so critical to every aspect of our
Waking Life and fortunately there are
also zeroc cost and lowcost behavioral
supplement based and prescription drug
approaches to improving this incredible
thing we call working memory so it was a
pleasure to share some of those with you
today as well if you're learning from
and or enjoying this podcast please
subscribe to our YouTube channel that's
a terrific zeroc cost way to support us
in addition please subscribe to the
podcast on both Spotify and apple please
also check out the sponsors mentioned at
the beginning and throughout today's
episode that's the best way to support
this podcast if you have questions for
me or comments about the podcast or
guests or topics that you'd like me to
host on the hubman Lab podcast please
put those in the comments section on
YouTube I do read all the comments
during today's episode and on many
previous episodes of The hubman Lab
podcast we discuss supplements while
supplements aren't necessary for
everybody many people derive tremendous
benefit from them for things like
improving sleep for hormone support and
for focus us to learn more about the
supplements discussed on the hubman Lab
podcast you can go to live momentus
spelled o us so that's liv.com huberman
if you're not already following me on
social media I am huberman lab on all
social media platforms so that's
Instagram Twitter now called X threads
Facebook and Linkedin and on all of
those platforms I discuss science and
science related tools some of which
overlaps with the content on the hubman
Lab podcast but much of which is
distinct from the content on the hubman
Lab podcast again that's hubman lab on
all social media platforms if you
haven't already subscribed to our
monthly neural network newsletter the
neural network newsletter is a
completely zeroc cost newsletter that
provides podcast summaries and protocols
in the form of brief PDFs of one to
three pages in which I detail things
like how to do deliberate cold exposure
and some of the science behind it how to
regulate your dopamine levels how to
improve your sleep and on and on
everything from Focus neuroplasticity
and all of which is available again
completely zero cost by going to
huberman lab.com go to the menu tab
scroll down a newsletter and simply sign
up by providing your email and I want to
emphasize that we do not share your
email with anybody thank you once again
for joining me for today's discussion
about working memory and ways to improve
your working memory and last but
certainly not least thank you for your
interest in
[Music]
science